Michael was still a major hurricane when
it cross the border into southwestern
Georgia last night it is the most
powerful storm ever recorded in that
part of the state it causes you see
widespread damage and one death an 11
year old girl was killed when a tree
fell on her home more than 230,000 homes
and businesses in Georgia are still
without power right now
mark Strassmann is in Roberta Georgia
where there's tornado damage from
Michael mark good morning to you good
morning one of the many ways that
hurricanes can be so destructive is
because they spawned tornadoes and that
is what happened here if you take a look
at those sheared rooftops behind me the
tornado came charging through here
swatting down trees and powerlines and
damaging homes in fact at least seven
homes were damaged just in this rural
neighborhood it also rained all night in
South and Central Georgia in fact some
parts of the state could see up to six
inches of rain a hundred eight counties
in Georgia are under a state of
emergency this morning
that's nearly 70 percent of the state
power crews are out assessing power
losses and trying to restore power to
the roughly quarter-million people who
are now without it that will take days I
want to give you one more testimonial to
just how powerful this hurricane was I'm
standing 250 miles from where Michael
made landfall and yet it was still
strong enough to cross into Georgia as a
category 1 it's the first category one
to hit the state of Georgia since
nineteen since 1898 think about that
1898 this is the last time a major
hurricane crossed into the state of
Georgia Breanna mark I'll take it back
from you pardon me
wow that's that's some time yeah